[Music]
it's my husband he's gone missing
missing I'm terribly worried
it's just Fred's never been gone this
long before how long has he been missing
since the funeral well I can start right
away there private investigator my
profession is very complicated okay it's
nuanced you be people and charge money
yeah sad isn't it how much would you
charge to be my friend Janet what how
much you got 20 bucks that's good this
conversation is over
the mob is trying to spread its
operation to Los Angeles somehow my
daughter Mia is involved please find her
I've seen this girl what's in it for me
oh we can do this the easy way how
you're currently doing it the easy way
whatever happened to offering me 20
bucks it's the recession this is a
high-profile case made the newspapers
[Music]
[Music]
you beat up on me part of the job I
accept it but why did you do to piss me
off
[Music]
[Applause]
before we go solving the crime of the
century let's deal with the rotting
corpse talk to her she's got a really
cute smile chin it's the last day I need
to go for the end of your budget numbers
and we just graduated and off to college
to do it right I can't hear you
I can't soundproof glass nobody knows
that we are fun they didn't party
because we wanted to focus on school and
get into good colleges and it worked
with the irresponsible people who
partied also got into those colleges we
have to go to a party tonight what
[Music]
beautiful out you to be this few who
will have you to take my breath away
it's a mystery party you're looking for
Nick's party
hey adorable farmer no to the city no no
we don't need Baran orthodontist I am i
baron
tonight is your night
[Applause]
ladies we are headed to the biggest
coolest grad night party in town can I
get a well that's a shotgun just kidding
[Music]
mark my calendars to attend the drama
department summer program was actually
funny it's what we did in my sermon
program last year in Barcelona when I
lived in
I would use your theater when you could
do debate because some of us enjoy
working with others some of us know how
to win nobody's winning in that outfit a
[Music]
relationship is something that requires
constant work I just feel like sometimes
he's not even trying anything seriously
he's terrified of being by himself given
all these strong feelings
what don't you hold hands he's literally
reaching out for you well my house you
got to interlock it though if you don't
interlock it might as well just be
friends I'm not partners you realize you
just destroyed it half of Metrocity port
is half not destroyed because you
weren't doing the same undercover
students than you did the first time do
the same thing everyone's happy how you
like Jump Street now hey I got a big ass
raised to babysit you two again
no you look like you about B you going
to MC say welcome to college foot shower
caddy beanbag chair someone's bringing a
ton of that stuff down to Mexico for
spring break
excuse you go first
yes remember me I'm your best nightmare
I'm your worst night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would you be on your toes follow me
sleepy what's so holy everyone saying
about your CP you like the Mexican
Wolverine are you not talking tonight
we're taking game night up a notch oh
boy
someone in this room is going to be
taken it's gonna be up to you to find
them it's a murder-mystery party whoever
finds the victim wins the grand prize
you're not gonna know what's real and
what's fake wait a second can't just
come in here and break the door the
whole
guys make sure you get a piece of this
cheese suppose one that's all this is
just okay Roger dad you drive safe
I've always enjoyed the camaraderie of
good friends
competing in games of chance and skill
[Music]
do I fell yeah this seems like wine you
could first I'm scared
[Music]
it's not a joke people are in real
danger Oh
what
[Music]
so much worse
stop wait me I have kids at home now
with an ass like yet you don't oh thank
you oh no he died this instructions on
how to remove the bullets didn't have
rubbing alcohol so I got you this lovely
shark good idea way to pivot and then I
squeaky toy for the pain Susan you take
Jerry to be your husband what's the
difference between Episcopalian and
Lutheran Episcopalians don't need fish
that's pescetarian us not a religion
they're all fanatics I don't know you
you may kiss the bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please tell me what's going on here our
group of friends has been playing the
same game of tag for 30 years what for
the entire month of May every year we
play tag you never know when someone's
gonna pop up congratulations buddy
your head doing great Anna our buddy
Jerry is the best that ever played I
know wants to retire never been tagged
just saying it was it touched here we
get here super nice your watches I don't
know how to do that I don't wear a watch
time is a construct
[Music]
it's game has given us a reason to be in
each other's wine think your dad would
have really wanted you to be seems like
the game was really flipped you guys
connected overly a competitive sometime
it's not about trying to get away from
each other it's actually about having a
reason to be around each other so how
long you been sober
oh no I'm not sober am i right now I'm
just here to tag my friend
he thinks he's caught me off guard oh my
god I've caught him off guard
hazelnut coffee what kind of [ __ ]
drinks hazelnut
let me just begin by saying that there
are two sides to every story and this is
my side the right one I used to be
anonymous nothing and nonentity only
that's your name right
yeah we've had nine classes together
since kindergarten mm-hmm
so here it is part one Brandon just a
couple hours ago you told me you were
gay
you said I should pretend to be straight
I didn't mean with me I am tormented
every day at school just one good
imaginary fling which brings us to part
two all of Brandon went and make a
convincing yeah what thank you I thought
pretending to lose my virginity would be
a little more special Judy Blume's
should have prepared me for that
I know tell me what you did for know he
told me the truth I was hoping that
maybe the same for me
so whether I liked it or not I was open
for business 20% off to Bath and Body
Works is that how much your imaginary to
respond to you I faked rocked your world
we need to pray for her but we also need
to get her the hell out of here no on
Monday things took a turn for the
scandalous screw all these people Oliver
ironically we were studying The Scarlet
Letter this girl named Hester Prynne has
an affair with Minister is besmirched
and made to wear read a for adulterer
perhaps you should embroider a read a on
your wardrobe I'm not proud of this but
you kind of look like a stripper no a
high-end stripper for governors or
athletes
everyone's talking about yes I know
exactly you're doing if I promise not to
tell anyone I kiss you right now
[Music]
I had a similar situation when I was
your age I had a horrible repetition why
because I saw a whole bunch of people
mostly guys mom there's a higher power
that will judge you for your indecency
Tom Cruise
the best we could ever play James
Franco's having a giant party can't
believe people still invite in places
[Music]
[Applause]
No
the Sheriff's Office is urging people to
stay in their homes right now I think
it's the apocalypse it's all in here the
Book of Revelations
Emma Watson showed up I hid in a dream
pipe for days just try and get some
sleep
I'm a massive Harry Potter fan I cannot
wait to answer all these amazing
question about how they made those
motion pictures take it easy Dumbledore
this is my king
[Music]
just because a bunch of movie fell into
a pole outside is when we can't have
some fun
there weren't your best friends hanging
out it's like a sleepover two-spirit
[Music]
Scarface style oh you guys yeah there we
go
yeah this is the best way so I will work
this evening neighbor I need a dance
table fight don't get too close the guy
has two hook hands you know neighbor
you're a pot dealer
I have image of marijuana down in Mexico
bring it back here by Sunday night I
will pay you $100,000 I bought an orca I
make a lot of money you probably gonna
get a search of the border you could
wear a disguise Batman how would you
like to make 10 grand means
costing the border alone huge red flag
but families I then get a second look so
we need you to be my wife
are you ready amazing I hired this dork
that lives in my building your new
sister we just have to dress up with the
squeaky clean all-american family is my
son Kenny Miller my lovely daughter
Casey I'm here to pick up no one cooks
inside the RV good you folks can make
camp with the Fitzgeralds tonight when
you've been married as long as we have
if you're looking to spice things up a
bit it never touched another woman
before I would be okay with that
so I guess we're swam oh yeah ooh there
we go
turns out that we stole from an
international drug dealer you all die
now as a family my wife she's just a
cheap stripper okay prove it let's get
naked shake your moneymaker baby i'ma
show you
have some respect that's your mother
[Music]
tarantula I can't feel my bingo
yesterday but too many storms of comecon
leaving a trace if not what God given me
is it because my life in ten shades are
great afraid I'll tend fade away sound
and praise and for the sunny day since a
man's daughter is the center of his
universe then one day you come face to
face with the love of her life get him
up here please fifty a little surprise
sent her Christmas cards oh yeah it says
happy holidays and everything it says
happy holidays oh I guess that's on me
forever now
your boyfriend is this internet
zillionaire Laird has no filter but he's
a really good guy remember that night in
the hot tub staff opened up like a
flower you should have seen it I
shouldn't have seen it but now I feel
like I have no father would want their
daughter with this guy I don't like
bodyguards around so I just have to stop
training these strange as they come the
reaction is keeping
I'm gonna ask Stephie to marry me and I
really like your blessing you know give
me a couple days when you over by
Christmas you're gonna be calling me son
how many calling you don't think that's
gonna happen I think it's gonna dad I
know it won't dad it will suck up but
Dad that stuff that dad what are you
talking about this is not someone if you
want our daughter Mary I am gonna take
this guy down you're gonna say anything
that Stephanie about the proposal right
trout
Laird spying on us with me
[Music]